مع حلولي فصل الشتاء ومع اقتراب بذكرى
السنويه الاولى للعمليات العسكريه الروسيه
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه الشهر المقبل نشرت
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز مقالا اشارت فيه الى
سعي الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الى
اعداد الروس وجيشه لمعركه طويله في
السنوات المقبله وهذا بعد اعتراف الكلام
السريع بالخسائر الجماعيه التي تسببت بها
اوكرانيا في نهايه الاسبوع الماضي خصوصا
في مدينه مكافحه نيويورك
على الجبهه الداخليه
ويسعى الى تجنب اي استياء المحتمل بشان
العواقب الوخيمه للحرب حيث كان قد اسرى في
وقت سابق قرار
بصدر قرارا بانشائي نظام لتدريب المتخصصين
في تطوير وانتاج المسيارات واكد ايضا ان
الغرب لم يحقق اهدافه في تدمير البلاد
مضيفا ان من بدا تلك العقوبات
التدمير الكامل للصناعه والتمويل والنقل
الروسي لكن لم يحدث هذا
بحسب تعبيره
[موسيقى]